Welcome to another Zoom call number of questions came in make sure you chat in your questions and when we get through these and we'll get to the chat questions always remember to go to your member site to look for any updates that might be.
Any changes that we made.
Remember that you can call and make an appointment with me.
We call that educational coaching call to keep us safe from the predators of the medical association.
And we ask that you just complete that coaching call request form right there it's on the old page of the member site.
So we can get ahead and see what you want to discuss.
Don't forget that you have access to all our courses and our blog posts.
Let's jump to the question.
That's cutters you wanted to know by vitamin D level and it.
Well 79.6 I currently am taking three 80 K.
So the 80 K.
That comes.
80 K.
Avail has 5,000 I use a vitamin D vitamin D measure to the international units.
So 15,000 I use it.
Remember vitamin D is a fat soluble vitamin. So, you know, if you're not dealing with low vitamin D levels.
You don't necessarily even need to take vitamin D on a daily basis will store your body.
So what are the proper levels of vitamin D? Well, depending on what lab runs your tests.
Because different labs have the right to say what is a normal range or not.
So most labs will say 30 to 80 is a normal range of vitamin D 30 to 80 desolators per milliliter.
And it's, but as I written it by book and we've talked about this before.
I really want my patients to have a vitamin D level of 50 to 150.
So if you're over, if you're at like one, if you were, if you said your vitamin D level was 179.
And I would say, okay, dropped out to one a day or take, you know, one every other day.
Is that too high? Is there a danger of getting too high of vitamin D?
Well, but you think is, you could be able to balance, right?
But even somebody who has, you know, vitamin D at 179, I still don't think that's really too high.
I still, I don't think you necessarily don't need to be taking as much vitamin D exogenously if you're, if you're at 179.
But if you're at 79, I'd keep taking three.
If it takes three 80K complete, which is 15,000, I use a day to get you at seven, to get you at 79.
Then you really need to be taking three.
You know, is somebody else had a last week had a vitamin D of 45 or something like that.
Is that too low? Well, no, technically, that's totally within range.
Except if you're trying to, you know, stimulate an immune response and vitamin D can, the beauty of vitamin D is it's immune modulating.
And it'll protect you from an auto immune response and it'll help your body fire or response against a cancer or a pathogen.
So higher, higher is better for sure.
So if I was at my test and my vitamin D and I was 40, I would start taking 80K or a vitamin D up 10 to 15,000, I use that I get it rechecked again.
You really wanted above 50. That's the goal. I've been drinking five pounds of juiced carrots per day.
So five pounds of carrots, juiced per day for two months now, sense of diagnosis, a metastatic breast cancer, a sort of natural chemotherapy.
Do you agree?
So yes, juiced carrots is at a natural chemotherapy.
Well, juiced carrots can be a good source of nutrition.
Is that a natural chemotherapy? No, I wouldn't agree with that. It's good source of good solid nutrition, which is beneficial for your immune system.
The negative thing about juiced carrots is that it does have a lot of glucose in it and it can raise your glucose levels.
So if your cancer is really driven through glycolysis, then it can be a wrong thing to do.
But if juiced carrots over the course of the last two months and your cancer hasn't grown.
Then I wouldn't be so concerned about that.
Juiced carrots also has.
Juiced anything also has some negative things that they that the juiced Pro juiced people don't talk about is that that's all wrong.
Well, they talk about that as positive, because since it's all raw nutrition, that it has all the enzymes in it, you haven't cooked it and ruined it and destroyed all the nutrition in it.
But I just I just don't buy that. So if you if you're juicy, you're basically pre-digesting things. So you're breaking things down to, you know, you know, very small size that molecular size, but very small size.
So it's easier for you to digest. So you're pre-digesting it, but you still have to absorb those things.
You still need enzymes secreted by your pancreas in a nothing hefty dose in order for you to be able to break it down to molecular size for you to absorb that.
And as we end up with less of those, even if you're taking oral enzymes, you're taking an exogenous enzyme capsule, you can still have some issues with digesting raw food.
So people go on a raw food diet thinking that that's the best because they listen to crisp work or something like that.
And they're over 30 years old and they're taking their juicing, you know, 10 glasses of juicity.
And they're getting got got issues and things like that because they're not really absorbing very well.
And so even if it's better nutrition because you're juicing, if you're not absorbing it, you're just deposited into the toilet.
So it's going through this tube called your intestinal track and it's going right into the toilet.
You're not getting the nutrition out of it that you really should.
That in fact, there's a diet called the gaps diet. So when people are really ill, especially when they have bad gut issues from food sensitivities and all sorts of things like that.
Which candid up leading to cancer, which can people may be listening to this, I've been into that category.
The gaps diet, you're not taking anything raw, you're basically making soup out of everything.
So you're making a soup out of your vegetables, you're cooking it all day long and it's predigesting it itself.
And the juicing proud will go, oh, you're killing the enzymes, enzymes aren't destroyed by that.
You're still going to get the benefit out of the nutrients that you're breaking down the nutrients into a particle size that is predigested just like juicing.
And it's going to be a lot easier on your body and on your gut to be able to absorb those things.
You're not throwing away all the vitamins in the carrots because you're drinking the soup, you're eating the broth too.
So I don't fall into the category that juiced is the right thing to do for everyone.
Now understand, if you're, if your cancer is a fed mainly off of glycolysis and you're able to tolerate juice, like the taste of it and you're absorbing a lot of it.
And it's doing well for you, I'm not against it, but I'm not a person that thinks that you should be going on a raw food diet in order to heal your cancer.
I think any of those diets like that can be wrong for a lot of people.
Also, I just received my genetic report and there is a beta carotene gene, the BCMO gene, this person's talking about the BCMO gene is a gene that those genes, what they do is help make an enzyme to break down vitamin A.
The person has a lot of BCMO gene defects, they don't break down vitamin A and don't utilize the vitamin A, so they actually need to take, it may be a good thing to take more vitamin A.
So if you're juicy carrots, you're getting beta carotene from the carrots, so that is the right thing to do.
You know, for just based upon that gene eating more carrots would be the right thing to do, so for that gene defect, supporting it with increasing your vitamin A through food, aka carrots is the right thing to do.
The cancer continues to grow on my one remaining kidney, I would like to discuss taking Ivermectin in the clinics ability to provide me with it.
So Ivermectin and again, we've spoken about this a lot in the last year as a highly overlooked and underutilized and under spoken about use of an off label, an off label use of a drug.
Ivermectin is a drug that's an anti parasitic drug that has been shown and there are some studies you can google them, there are some studies that show that Ivermectin can kill cancer.
So I'm all for taking Ivermectin, there really isn't any downsides, there's really not really any, it's one of those drugs that have been used for decades and decades, what's very, very little.
Side effects, so as far as the critics ability to provide you with that, we have no ability to provide you with that because the only over the culture Ivermectin is for horses.
If you could buy that at a barbed fleet store, fleet farm store, and take that based upon your weight, but that has to be done by you and I can't oversee that.
So if you want to get the human prescribed, Ivermectin you'll have to go to a prescribed doctor to be able to get that.
The tumor board met last week and suggested doing three rounds for nine weeks of chemotherapy to debulk the next tumors before you eat radiation in the fall she suggested these three medications these three.
People therapy drugs she said it will be harsh, especially the five FU because that's a combination one.
It will cause mouse sores along with other terrible side effects, well, at least they're being honest with you.
Or you could use these three still using the five FU or you could use these three.
We did discuss these so I don't know what the side effects you know you have any thoughts about these.
We've had patients that have used all sorts of different combination chemotherapies and understand you know there's I cannot tell people legally or even morally and ethically that people therapies not the right thing to do because we've had people literally I think saved their life take and doing some chemotherapy.
So and the other thing is even if we had 10 people that did this combination for whatever type of cancer, you're even if it was the exact same type of cancer that you have it's still not going to be telling how you're going to respond the positives or negative response that any single person will have to that same combination of drugs just because your body reacts so differently than everything else.
I would say this and I said this you know dozens of times in the past if you're going to choose to do chemotherapy going to have a positive outlook on it.
Can't be all down to the dumps you can't be all sad about it because you want to go okay I'm choosing to do this that God is leading me to do this I am going to you know believe in my heart that God's going to use this to kill the cancer knock this down.
If you go into any type of protocol they keep I feel like I'm losing and I feel like I you know doing something I don't want to do and as you go and you agree to do it because you feel like it's your only option I just don't think you're going to have as good a results I think there's a lot of evidence that support that comment that I just made.
And I just don't think that's the right way to do it I mean if you really really honestly feel so negatively and I'm talking about the person who wrote this I'm just talking in general anybody if anybody feels so negatively about people therapy that don't do it tell you feel like you have permission to do it.
Have a good attitude about anything that you choose to do know that God is going to protect you in all those things that he's going to have his hand on you and yeah you're going to do some things like we talked about last week about fasting for 24 hours before the IV and then going off your your
antioxidants for 48 hours post chemo and then going and hit it hard with antioxidants and doing foot baths on a daily basis to pull that stuff out of your body and trust that God is going to protect you through this and he's going to use this.
So I know people have asked me personally how and son AJ who had
leukemia how he's doing it just spoke with her text back and forth yesterday of the day before again just to recheck with her again he's doing fantastic he did do the chemo and I am convinced if he wouldn't have done the chemo he would have passed away he was his cancer was just just went bonkers.
And he was on death's door before it was all figured out so if just you know God can use anything he could use chemo to heal you so you know just have that attitude that if God is leading you towards doing chemo or radiation or surgery whatever it is
you know just you know doesn't mean you go in there blind lead you're going to do it because you know you're you know you're making a foolish decision but be praying about it and trusting that his head is going to be in it and you're going to be protected through it.
So other part of this question I can't tell you which combination is better I can't tell you if I do that answer nobody knows the answer manufacturer colleges to say they don't know that answer.
It's just their protocols that they followed and the only reason why they have this protocol versus putting everybody on this is because some people will start on their primary protocol and they'll get sick and they'll think that you know they reacted negatively towards something and it was they'll switch out of one of the products so
that it's just good practice of medicine so that's why they have you know different protocols because some people have allergies towards different drugs too.
I lost 20 pounds this winter from going vegan but can't put weight back on I feel like my metabolism is on hyperdrive and I am kexia I think I answered this question last week but is there a way to reverse this and gain the weight and muscle.
I'm sticking to the diet you gave me and eating as much as possible yeah go back to the blog search that word kexia and I think I have a video and a bunch of different things to do if you truly do have kexia even if you have so even if you're I mean kexia is to find that you're losing two to five pounds a week no matter what you're doing you kid you're in this plummet of weight loss.
But I doesn't sound like that's what it is maybe you lost the 20 pounds you feel like you're underway you're stable now but you want to gain weight back you can still go to the blog and search kexia because there's things that you can do and follow in there that can help you gain what's on weight back on.
About a year ago I did the saliva test the cheek swab test or the clinic the results indicated that the drivers of my cancer.
Are histamine dairy and toxins will I need to eat low histamine and avoid dairy the rest of my life well I don't remember what your histamine genes are but if you don't have a lot of defects and your histamine genes and we didn't point that out in your genetic testing then the answer to that is no you will not have to eat low histamine you know low histamine diet the rest of your life.
If you're in a full remission so if the person's in full remission of their cancer and dairy and histamine or drivers of their cancer so let's say you have no genetic issues with histamine that I'd say going back on some histamine food slowly and carefully would be fine going back and eating some good organic dairy especially butter would be just fine.
If you have a lot of genetic issues with histamine that's going to be just an issue forever those genetic issues are never going to go away.
Nobody should be eating a lot of dairy, no one can have cancer or not.
Personally I don't drink any milk with I butter but I do eat some cheese but well okay is there another test to determine which toxins are driving the cancer well if your cancer is in remission it may not that they may show with the cheek swab test is there other tests to determine what toxins you have that could be an issue your cancer.
Yes there's lots of other tests so if you went to the lab store and so there's some good tests that I would say would be beneficial to look at if you're looking at specific toxins.
And here's two of them so the gpl tox test looks for glyphosate the mycotoxins test looks for mycotoxins mycotoxins are from mold those are two things that you could look at this gpl test test is under utilized for sure so glyphosate.
So glyphosates are a huge issue and a huge problem in our environment so though there's lots of different ways that you can measure these things by running these different tests.
There is a so I'm just looking at real questions quick through the oxic tests that you could run there is a metals hair test that you could do that you could do that gives you a picture of.
Toxic and metals in by doing a hair analysis test but it's so as far as toxins go then there are some Syrex panels I think it's the array well no not the array 12 that will measure if you have antibodies to toxins.
So that's a whole other picture so you know if I have toxins in my body it's the array 11 so the Syrex array 11 measures antibodies to different toxins and biomarkers, which is a whole other ball of wax if people have serious illness that they you know have been a lot of different places and can't get better some of these.
Functional medicine tests is what's measured in the array 11 can be really beneficial because you could actually end up developing antibodies to different toxins now you have these antibodies and every time you're exposed to these things now you fire a reaction to those.
If you also have self antibodies meeting antibodies to self tissue like person would in Hashimoto's like most of you probably do because autoimmune disease is so rampant and I wrote about in my book you know when it first came out 2010 that I think cancer has an autoimmune component with every single person.
So if you really want to fight dig deeper in tests so a lot of people you know they come to me and they just you know they're having serious issues with cancer they just want to get better once they get into the remission and I want to go any farther and then there's some people like possibly the person who asked this question actually on the wrong question here but the person that asked this question.
I want to dig a little deeper and find out some other things that can be going on they might be in full remission but I want to dig deeper and and figure out some other things if you want to find out if you have antibodies to self tissue the best test I think is the Syrex array five so that test is
measures self a good array of self antibodies self tissue antibodies and really gives you an idea if you what other things that you have going on.
If you have a lot of brain fog brain issues I can figure out why I can think straight I'm concerned about about all cybers then the array 14 and the array seven X are really good this is the array five it on the biomarkers that a test for these are antibodies to all these different.
Self tissues that are so important these are hidden a lot of people the array 14 gives you the APO antibodies it really looks at the brain antibodies as far as.
Antibodies as far as all cybers disease go so you can really measure whether I you know have to make some drastic lifestyle changes so that I.
You know can push all cyber all cyber and dementia diseases as far out into the future as possible the array seven array seven X seven X is a little more expanded is antibodies to neural tissue so different neurons micro glial cells.
And other glial cells and myelin she sells and things like that because that's a huge issue with people especially after doing chemo it's one of the issues that they have with what a quote a quote chemo brain is they actually have antibodies to their own tissue or they have micro glial primate which either one causes inflammation of the brain.
And that's a lower than half lecture right there if you want to go look more about that go to my video on.
Issues that could happen with brain inflammation I think if you go to the blog and you search.
Great inflammation you could find out more information about that okay so a person said in a list of this is what I asked a lot of you to do so many times you are taking what you guys start with me you're taking a bunch of different supplements so this is an example of persons taking a bunch of different supplements that none of this is ours right so.
And when I do the testing I may say okay.
I may go okay this is let's pretend that that's let's say sec didn't test well at all and i'll just say stop so i'll say stop this stop this stop this in all of you know what i'm talking about because I did this when I did your original testing there's things that you're taking that I told you to stop taking.
And then there's things that I said well you can keep taking that as long as if you want and and sometimes i've told you and you can keep taking if you run out and let me know and many times you.
Many of you have let me know when you do run out of things so I can say oh you don't need that anymore it was nothing wrong with you taking it but now that you're out don't keep taking it I don't want you guys taking 500 different supplements so.
So just make sure let's say if you're it's even better if you're like a week away I have one week left let's say I didn't tell you to take the sec but you felt led to take the x sec then make sure you be able to have one week left in the sec and then maybe we should set up a time to talk about whether you should keep taking that or not so.
But because we're testing your cheek swab and you're taking all this stuff we're testing you when you're taking that stuff so.
I only take you off things that I think that are bad for you that are poor poorly key laid admitted rules are supplements with methyl groups that.
You know just there's other reasons why I may take you off something end of a questions for coffee animals example the s a Wilson's coffee why is it so light colored is it not roasted what are the advantages compared to Starbucks dark roast.
Well dark roast coffee that's my favorite that's Starbucks but I just like dark roast the darker the roast the I to me it has more flavor because you get that roasted flavor some people like light roast honestly I think the reason why they like light roast is because they get more buzz off of it why because the lighter the roast the more caffeine in it.
So this essay Wilson's coffee if you.
Cooked it up in your coffee pot and drink it and probably spit it out and throw it away because it's gross it's not meant to be drink and drink it's meant to be used in coffee and it's very very lightly roasted if roasted at all it's specifically for coffee animals because it has such high caffeine in it so if you're not going to go with the essay Wilson's coffee and hey I don't have.
Committee I just need to do a coffee animal get the lightest roast possible and try to get an organic one.
For the coffee animal what part of the intestine absorbs this it's down in the rectum by only have 11 centimeters before the tumor will it still absorb probably you're not really trying to absorb this so.
It's not really the absorption of it's it's stimulation you don't have to absorb any of it it's the stimulation of the vagal nerve and it's in the lower rectal area just above the a to so yeah you still have.
If you really have seven 11 centimeters before the tumor will it still absorb properly that's her is yes it's not going to be absorbed properly you're still stimulating the biggest nerve.
Also doing sodium bicarbonate animals the reason why this person would be good to do sodium bicarbonate animals.
So would everybody do a sodium bicarbonate no this person has a tuber 11 centimeters up so that's why he's trying to get the sodium bicarbonate baking soda.
Alcolidity into the tumor with fragrance and lemon grass oils while it smells great one of the benefits of these essential oils in the animal these are cancer killers in themselves that's why you would do it.
I can still only get about eight ounces at most of fluid in the animal I guess that's okay yes that is perfectly okay that's fun try to hold it five minutes.
Sometimes it go in a minute a little bit longer that's great that's perfect so it would great.
Hi Dr. Cutters does it matter where I put the bulb under the cover I have breast cancer also I do the right every night but I only get to do the full time on the weekends I normally get seven hours of my programs that's okay.
Yes that's okay you're getting you know I put the program in and you know I mix up the frequencies through every night so you're not missing anything if you were say if you call and said, hey I only sleep four hours okay well that's a problem but if you're getting seven of the eight to half nine hours you're doing fine.
Where do you put the bulb you just as close to you as you feel comfortable that's you just put it as close to you as you feel comfortable even if there's clothing or something in between you.
Also I wanted to do that counteract program and I called to write to get a stand but they said there was not one for the model of right I have so I think they meant there's not a stand for the bulb you have there's not a stand for the hammer bulb there's only a stand for the qx to or the double bubble bulb.
You have any suggestions where I could place the bulb so that is one foot away from my eyes for an hour or 15 minutes yeah you could just you could put it on the back of your neck so you doesn't have to be you don't have to be shiny at your eyes I wouldn't you recommend that but yeah you could put it under your neck you could put it on the back of your neck it's going through your head you just you know you don't wouldn't want to put it by your feet because it's too far away from your eyes so you could you if you sit in a lazy boy chair so.
You could put it underneath your neck and you can lay there like that that'd be a good thing or put it on the top of your head if you want.
I've been checking my glucose a bit after I wake up every morning for the last week by this bed between 89 and 107.
I think I spoke about this a little bit last week 89.
That's better 107 that's not good so but let's I'll talk more about that I notice that on days I take it at 8 am it's over 100 a days I take it at 9 it's around 90 this is the total number for me over the years but I haven't eaten so clean low calm.
So I'm going to do an intermittent fasting constantly could the hormone blocking medications on increased by glucose and or cortisol insulin and cause these higher numbers.
Possibly there's probably not a lot of research data about that but there anything's possible as far as using a drug so that is possible I haven't eliminated carbs completely but only eats very.
There's various apples and a slice of the Zekiel bread written down by dinners and there's no correlation example the morning after I had some culverse chocolate custard and a glass of white as a treat.
It was only 92 I've told my new colleges office I'm not taking another rejection or pill until I get my usual food but it'll start.
I will ask them if this is a side effect but what do they get your opinion while they probably will tell you you're better off just.
You know, a line search if that's a side effect but I would highly doubt that that would you that you'd find that anywhere.
It's probably really hasn't been studied.
So back to getting your glucose levels down this is this is going to be the most common thing when you're talking about glucose levels as.
Hey my glucose is 92 no better what I do I can't seem to bunch that well sorry but this is just life your glucose levels yes have to do with what you eat but it has more to do with your cells and the cell membranes ability to receive that glucose and get inside the cells.
And the longer we live the more exposed exposure we have to toxins that damage our cell membranes and then they're reproducing cells with damage cell membranes the less some more compromise that we had with our ability of ourselves to receive glucose the unique glucose in a daily life in order for it to break down through glycolysis for you to make ATP.
So it's not just your muscles that need that it's that's how every cellular function that you have is is reliant is dependent upon ATP.
So that's where as we age are our pancreas isn't making insulin as well we come more insulin resistant our cell membranes become insulin resistant and our cell membranes become more damage and less healthy in the glucose receiving receptors.
Don't work as well so it's not as easy you know if you if you were 23 years older you decided to start fasting it and clean up your diet you could probably take somebody who has a average glucose of a hundred and seven and get them down to in the eighties within a week as we age it's just sometimes it's possible I've had people that come to me for diabetes they don't have cancer they're glucose is.
It's two in the two hundreds we put them on a super super strict diet almost a ketogenic diet and it seems to do absolutely nothing for their glucose levels.
The reason is is if your glucose is set to 100 and it's it's it's it's diabetes diabetes just a name of a disease that means that your your glucose receptors on your cell membranes have been so damaged.
Now you could also have like a person can also have type one diabetes is completely different and that is an auto view disease of the island cells to the pay grace where you're not able to make insulin and that's totally different situation.
Oh to add to the glucose question a month ago or so I'd go to my colleges for my injections and before getting them they take my blood around 2 p.m. my glucose would come out at about 82 hours after eating lunch okay so little no in fact is that your glucose if you took your glucose right after you ate lunch even if it wasn't a high carb lunch your glucose will spike that's normal that's a post radial glucose.
Test and it's normal to spike up but then it drops down and then it balances out so that's why you wanted if you're going to be taking your glucose levels to measure your glucose levels you want to take it at a 10 or 12 hour fast on a regular basis.
Don't do this because it'll give you a false rating of oh it's down to 80 that's almost in the 70s that's really good yeah because it's just dropped it plummeted from a high after eating and now it'll go up 80 90 95 and then that will be your normal so it's not a fair assessment of really where your glucose levels are on average.
Okay we got a lot of questions that came into the chat L glutamine powder why is it not good for cancer patients because glutamine is a can be a direct fuel source for cancer so not with everybody but glutamine can be a direct fuel source of for cancer glutamine glutamine it with dieting.
So I write a lot about that in my book so it's a big no no you're going to you need glutamine you need glutamine to make glutamate which is an excitatory to are transmitted to your brain so don't get me don't get wrong that is an essential amino acid of your body but take a not exogenous glutamine for somebody who has a history of cancer it's just done right foolishness so you do not take glutamine why do you give a person why would anybody.
Why would a functional doctor recommend glutamine it's typically recommended with somebody who has got issues and if they have a damage got leaky got central take out glutamine it's great because it'll help yourselves really reproduce quickly and you can help heal your gut you know real nice.
Why because out glutamine is a really strong feeder especially for epithelial cells and you'll reproduce cells quite quickly why would you want to do that if you had any kind of history of cancer very dangerous I don't function medicine doctors that have no idea what they're doing with cancer and they'll recommend out glutamine for somebody because oh well we got to heal the gut everything begins in the gut you have cancer we need to heal the gut.
Absolute idiocy in my part so do not do that I'm not saying you but I'm saying the practitioner should know better here it's are also very high in oxalates yes and if you have oxalate issues that's another that you just got to be careful so just because the excursion said everybody should be do some carets but whenever you see anything that everybody should be doing that doesn't mean that that's wrong I mean everybody should be trying to eat organic but you got to it should be a red flag that you should be doing that.
Just at least question it right so everybody should go on a ketogenic diet if they have cancer I don't think so so same thing with everybody should use carrots because they have cancer I don't think so so just question things you know doesn't mean that's wrong doesn't mean it's wrong for you but just question it I was taking 10,000 I you every day all winter and still only reached 50 I'm now taking now at 45 so they're talking about their body.
Vitamin D level and then currently not taking vitamin D or K so if you have that vitamin D that I said last week on the zoom call if you have that vitamin D that you were taking before then go back to taking that if you don't get the 80 K avail from us or get that model that one that you have was a good form of vitamin D to vitamin D also take that and it would be good to take even 20,000.
I use if you were taking 10,000 every day through the winter and you only reached 50 you probably need more so don't feel bad about taking 20,000 I don't feel bad about anybody taking very high doses of vitamin D if they're measuring it so certainly won't want to be taking 20,000 I use a vitamin D and you never measure it your vitamin D can be over 200 but if you're measuring it it's still less than 100 you're not going to get that.
I'm not taking too much. All right my amylase is 139 lipase 86, human globin A1C is 5.8 LD fraction is 16, fraction 331 my white blood cell is abnormal should I be concerned we should have a talk and I don't know if you said I'm not looking at your your your your.
Note right now but I don't know if you said in your labs or not but we should probably have a discussion so call and read instead of a time to chat.
I'm going to do the right for about two months small tumors on the right proceed larger how long do I wait to determine whether the right is working and whether the frequency should be changed.
Well the frequencies for so typically the frequencies for the cancer so when you talk about breast cancer you probably not going to change the frequencies for the cancer itself but there may be other side things it might be good to send in a cheek swab so I can check to see if there's anything else going on that I need to add to your program so let's let's do that.
Send in another cheek swab and let me check to see if there's anything else I need to do differently cancer cannot grow in an alkaline body if that statement is true is there a list of foods to eat that supports an alkaline body enlisted foods that to avoid that doesn't support that well.
If anybody's been listening to me for any length of time they know that I don't believe that statement whatsoever and that is just there's so much untruth to that statement from a physiological perspective.
And I won't and I talk about this in my book I talk about this and different blog posts and a tons of different zoom calls but I'll just briefly explain the physiology your physiology is such that you do maintain a pH intracellular and extra sell it means inside cells and outside cells you'll maintain a pH and then in your blood.
But you even you maintain a very strict pH in your blood otherwise you'll die so how you maintain that pH is through your body's buffering systems your body has these buffering systems now there may be an area in your body that's more acidic at different times in an area that's more alkaline at different times but let's make it very clear.
You're in general you're going to stay maintained a pH that's fairly neutral just because something you know you've heard time and time again that you know cancer grows in an acidic environment you need to alkalize alkalize alkalize there's there's literally no truth to that statement whatsoever.
Any cell that's in rapid replication will give off a lot of waste so when there's a lot of waste waste is going to be acidic it'll be carried back through your limb system and out of your body it'll be carried into the blood through your limb system and it will be buffered so the acidity of that waste will be buffered in your blood now part of the buffering system that will take something that's acidic and make it alkaline
is that this is where you pull nutrients pull minerals from your other tissues and from your bones to help buffer it you also have a buffering system in your liver and in your stomach actually the creation of HCl by your stomach cells
actually produces a side creation of sodium bicarbonate which is used in your bloodstream as a buffering system for the blood so the production of HCl in your cyst in your stomach actually helps buffer through alkalizing the rest of your body you could say.
That's the thing I didn't have to talk about a lot with the total misnomer of people drinking alkaline water or taking sodium bicarbonate mix it in their water making it very alkaline water and drinking that you're really alkalizing the HCl in your stomach thereby actually acidifying your body.
So you have to understand physiology here so I would agree that the at the cancer site if you have a solid cancer not not the blood cancer is not multiple by Loma not leukemia but even not lymphoma in the blood but if you have a lymphoma hard solid tuber lymphoma.
At that solid tumor whether it's a breast cancer or brain cancer it is going to be if you could slice it open and stick a pH strip in there it is going to be more acidic simply because any rapid replication of cells are going to create an acidic area and an acidic slime layer of the cell.
So if we could inject the tumor of a sodium bicarbonate like Dr. Simon cheating did in Italy that might be beneficial hence why this person is doing a was it that asked that question here is doing sodium bicarbonate and of us because they have a cancer in the rectal area that the sodium bicarbonate could get at.
So they're trying to alkalize the tuber you're not killing the tuber by alkalizing it but you're breaking down the acidic layer that you're so your immune system can better get at it to kill it so a long story short you're when you're eating good foods.
You are helping your body stay buffered when you're getting good minerals you're helping your body in its buffering system the idea that is out there the alternative community that you eat meat you're acidifying your system and your damaging your system is just complete physiological nonsense.
I'm sorry but there's there's doctors who write books about this stuff and you can't just this is the kind of bothers me and I get a little hot head in about this stuff because it makes alternative doctors look foolish to anybody who's actually reads the science and understands physiology so.
So you're not your purpose is not to alkalize your body your purpose is to get your body healthier you if you could inject the tuber with sodium bicarbonate around the tumor maybe they'd be benefits to that we still don't know about that you can't legally do that and there could be other dangers of doing that so I wouldn't recommend doing that but.
To read some more of my stuff about that to really understand the physiology so I think that will help you.
I think there's a lot of misinformation out there and that misinformation bothers me because it makes all alternative doctors seem foolish and I think that's not good.
How do I get enough fat on a keto like diet without dairy and I eat rice and sweet potatoes on this diet well.
Technically if you're going completely keto no you can't eat rice but I don't think they even allow sweet potatoes on a full keto diet but if you're in a keto like diet yes you can eat rice and you can eat some sweet potatoes so a keto like diet is defined by the person who's doing the diet so you're not going full keto.
As far as getting fat without dairy there's some really good recipes for coconut oil bombs and things that are out there that are actually just delicious using coconut if you like coconut you have to like coconut oil I guess really to go keto but that's some ways to do it.
I certainly would suggest that eating some rice and sweet potatoes in your can the persons asking this question's condition would be.
You recommend putting chlorine from a health food store into water to make it alkaline for consumption.
I think you're talking about chlorine dioxide MMS putting chlorine you would not put chlorine in your water to make it more alkaline so I'm not sure what you're talking about there is a therapy using chlorine dioxide which is MMS but it's not to make your it's not to alkalize it's it's that that.
That procedure is to kill pathogens there is a chlorine dioxide treatment for cancer but I think it's I don't think there's a validity to that I think there is validity to use in chlorine dioxide for pathogens or live disease and different things for short periods of time as far as chlorine using what you don't want chlorine in your water it's toxic.
I had more 5-inch worm like specimens after continuing with the hpilora program and the rights is person shared that with us a couple of weeks ago should I start the dewormer I bought from you and how should I use it so if you're talking about the fed bend is all that you if you got it from our store comes three little packets in there that's a week's worth so just do it three days in a row one packet per day you could mix it in your smoothie.
It take it that way just one packet a day for three days that off for four days that's how I think also my emotions have been all over the place since this has been going on.
Well there is some emotional issues with passing parasites for some people because they're like oh my gosh it's just the anxiety of the passing parasites but then there also has been.
cases where passing parasites can affect us from an emotional perspective because it is affected a certain part of our brain what's called the amygdala of the brain where you actually hold a lot of.
you're how to how to put it memories that are are have a lot of emotional content to it usually those are negative memories so like you know memories of difficult situations my mother died when I was seven or I was abused when I was 10 or I broke my leg and I you know couldn't play my senior year of soccer.
things that have an emotional charge to it and there is data out there that passing parasites can bring those up and i'm not sure the neurological connection to that the to sit down and kind of figure that out but there is some some truth to that so.
there is a product called zeolite to detox the body do you know much about it yeah zeolite is we have zeolite in the clear binder product phase five clear binder.
I like zeolite it's a great binder it's a mild to moderate key later so it's something that people could use even if they have.
mercury fillings in their mouth still so zeolite a great binder and so technically a binder is something that you don't really absorb it's really acted in the gut and then a key later is something you absorb and it's acted in the tissues zeolite does both that's why it's in a lot of good binder products.
because it it bind stuff in the gut so that you don't reabsorb it but plus you will absorb zeolite and it'll grab things in the bloodstream so to help all stuff out of the tissues.
I refrigerated my specimen on Saturday should I have it checked out or is it no good at this point.
If you want to save a specimen of a parasite specimen you could put it in some vodka.
That would probably best protect it and usually if you just refrigerated it and it's you know in a paper towel or something like that and probably break down.
I would like to see some pictures of it so kind of weird that way but if you do pass some more I'd like to see some pictures if you could email them to labs at counters clinic I appreciate that.
I know i'm dairy free but would it be harmful to have a bite of cheese once every two to three weeks.
Yeah so I really believe that I mean there's some people that I probably almost everybody on this probably every patient I've ever had has a better diet than me most time so i'm just being honest but.
I do believe in moderation so even if I say go dairy free to to cheat every couple weeks when your families having something I don't think that's going to cause major issues so.
I know that most everybody would disagree with me because you're all more disciplined than I am so.
It will be four weeks on Thursday since my pet scans I noticed a rash on my back a day or two ago after the scans i've been taking three drops twice a day of your radiation will be a path to drops the rash on my back and up into my hairline remains and has spread to my front torso well i'm not sure.
that the i'm not sure what the rash is from so certainly I would say that the rash if you do a pet scan or CT scan right the what's the negative of that well pet scan you're getting you have to drink that glucose drink with CT scan and a pet scan you're getting radiation if they did give you anything else as far as.
A contrast die then it's simply the radiation that you're exposed to you're not going to get a rash from the glucose drink.
But you certainly could get a rash from a contrast dies that's that's a chemical change of the radiation i'm not heard I mean definitely heard of people getting radiation therapy and we'll get a skin burn that looks like a rash but it's actually a bird of the skin from the.
I see the radiation i'm not heard of a rash from radiation so I don't I don't know that I can certainly be wrong and I don't know that the rash on your back a day or two after the scans was due to the was due to the scans if the scans did not if you did not get a contrast dying at the scans.
So the radiation homeopath is just to help pull out the radiation out of your body certainly anything's possible but for it to get worse that just makes me think that it's so what are some possible reasons for a rash well i'll tell you you know what the most so when you think of a rash you think of a histamine reaction.
On the skin so what causes a histamine reaction is an allergy to something or at a high exposure to something.
And your so the reason why your body releases histamines is to stimulate.
stimulate an immune response so if if that thing isn't a pathogen that your immune system can kill then you're just you're and you aren't getting rid of these histamines very well then that's what causes a rash person is exposed to you know dander of an animal or exposed to pollen they can get a rash or.
Or a toxin so toxic exposure let's say poison ivy you're going to get a rash because of the what's it urinal or something that's in poison ivy that oil is an irritant and it's going to cause skin irritation.
So if you have other reasons for rash can be toxins in your body that are being released stress related rash I remember when I was in school after my first trimester going through my first set of finals.
After I was after it was done I broke it out into a rash for two weeks over about two weeks Christmas vacation was an itchy horrible rash the entire two weeks and it was completely stress related my adrenals were burdened out over the years of practice just knowing that fact I see that time and time again where people's adrenals are just fried and that is the reason why they break out in a rash.
Has to do with your adrenals ability to interact with the HMT gene which helps you break down history to be in the tissue so i later figured that out so it's stress it's that that's why stress can cause those things so when you bird out of your cortisol levels and your adrenals are.
It's you know strong adrenal fatigue you can end up with all sorts of problems in rash it just one of them baking soda and salt bats helped me after pet scans oh thank you for that thank you so that can be helpful.
When I start doing smoothies with greens and fruits and four different real mushrooms I start feeling really bad and tired.
Okay so if you're like putting real you know mushrooms from the grocery store or the health would store in your smoothie mushrooms have a lot of micotoxins and so you won't have micotoxins in a mushroom capsule like you're taking a mushroom pill like turkey tail or you're taking our medicinal mushrooms but mushrooms themselves can have.
Different spores and certainly micotoxins and many mushrooms should be cooked before eating them so so I don't I wouldn't put raw mushrooms in nice movie so I would not do that.
But I mean detoxing too fast and too hard I don't think it's detoxing I think it'd be a sensitivity to the mushrooms I don't we I don't I mean sometimes I don't have raw mushrooms in a salad because I ordered it in a restaurant but I never put raw mushrooms on my salad I don't think we should be eating raw mushrooms honestly I think all our mushrooms should be cooked.
And better yet you know water processed in how water bath which is how you get our mushrooms that we use for medicinal mushrooms are used I think raw mushrooms can have issues I would not be eating raw mushrooms.
I'm high in metals arsenic how to detox these metals metals my second reason to make you a cancer patient okay so we do have to have a chat because I haven't you don't you remember you have access to these courses this course right here I wrote specifically because of a question just like this not from you but I've got this question.
I should over 35 years of practice I have high and heavy metals and I need to do chelation therapy I'm going to start right away go and start watching these videos of this course there's seven modules of this course and I know it's like I don't want to do that well then Colin I'll talk you through these but you need to understand the seventh phase detoxification that you just jump into chelation you're a very strong possibility make yourself very sick so I'll say no more.
Sorry said the rash question too soon I also have other itchy rectal and vaginal as well as much as you know all over even where there is no rash I take a daily detox bath baking soda have some salt charcoal essential oils daily plus copy and it was in soda could this be a history reaction what should I do about it.
I would I know you're going through a lot of stress maybe stress is that is the main issues your needles are just right.
I know let's see let's go back to this supplement list so what would you do if somebody's if somebody's needles are fried okay it's a medical term.
You use adaptogens it's first thing you go to is adaptogens you know somebody once said if you're on a deserted island you can only take one supplement with you what would it be well adaptogens would be right up there.
I'm being able to over read would be a part of my favorite medicinal washer but adaptogens would be right up there the pop by and the reason why it's because adaptogens help balance your hormones if they're too high they bring them down so if you're so there's different levels of adrenal stress so if you're under you know acute stress that you've had healthy adrenals your cortisol could be very high that could be very dangerous if you had a long term stress your cortisol and your adrenals could be just just.
Posted and your cortisol your epinephrine your epinephrine are just really low well wherever you don't need to you don't need to do a adrenal profile to know what you're at because you just take adaptogens it'll bring your high cortisol down into bring low cortisol up so let's just look real quick here if you have or take it you have adaptogens in your list here.
It's really mainly in adaptogens for estrogen that's a really good much for your adrenals so lute thiode is good if it is from radiation and I think we addressed this I've taken it from your proxide orally last week you really aren't on any adaptogens so getting a good adaptogen would be in order.
Are we have multiple adaptogens and we have multiple adaptogens private labeled either are adapt a clear or our court of clear would be good choice and adaptogens the way you know so I have people take adaptogens and they're taking like nine pills a day until they get through their stress.
You know thing and then you just certainly don't need to take them so adaptogens that are something that you necessarily take every day adaptogens you use like you would use a medicine or under a ton of ton of stress and it issues that you take a lot of adaptogens and then when things calm down and you're not under that ton of stress and you you put them in your cover till you only use them what you need what do you think a bind weed or end your genesis.
I don't have a lot of experience with that so I don't know I haven't seen a whole lot of data on bind weed so I can't clean it or you don't want end your genesis so if bind weed helps decrease end your genesis and that's what you want.
Is is equal to okay on a keto like diet well anything's okay on a keto like diet within reason so.
If you're doing a keto like diet make sure that you have a good cometer your measure and your morning glucose that's the way to measure if you really want to do full ketogenic then you actually get a ketone meter and so that's different but.
I would just do a good cometer far less expensive far easier to monitor remember is equal bread is not gluten free if you're out of gluten free diet just so you know.
Is the 8.8 alkaline water with electrolytes at the store okay to drink a friend said it's not considered clean water okay so that goes back to our shouldn't we drink alkaline water question by answer to that is.
No you shouldn't I don't think you should be drinking alkaline water I think it's a waste of money just drink good clean water you don't want to alkalize your stomach acid.
I got a phone call just as you are answering my question about when to change right frequencies and I didn't hear your reply so let's do a cheek swap so let's do a cheek swap just to check and see if there's anything else we need to answer to said in a cheek swap.
How do I get a fully updated list of supplement recommendations what we need to do another cheek swap I sent it my current list last week because when we tested you you were taking those things so we need to do another cheek swap and this is the list that I copied and tasted so I need to know what's your current this is with the cheek swap that you said did if you run out of any of these things take the.
off the list and send it a new updated list but you list everything I should be taking yes and I'll be more specific for you along do I do the odd and off the word protocol yes I bought the five boxes for you I would just if you have five boxes I just do five weeks in stock so five boxes should last you five weeks as you're going to do three days on four days on.
So that would be one box per week I had a contrast die through an objection for both the pets yeah then it could be the contrast die that you're reacting to so then you know as far as what you're taking right now that will help with the contrast die certainly glutes I will help you because that's the antioxidant will help.
with a breakey down what you had there looking if you have any binders or keylators in here zero light that will help so I maybe up those two things that would help.
of course it would certainly help it's not going to help pull out the die but it'll help decrease the inflammation you could increase in the night and the labels will glue here increase that until this the settles down he don't mojo makes a good key tone plus glucose monitor for about 50 bucks nice can stress increase morning glucose.
My hot flashes are worse at night so I wake up a lot at night either burning up or freezing not exactly relaxing.
Well you really want to understand the physiology of that the answer is if you have healthy adretals and you have stress and you're waking up at night yes you have a higher glucose in the reason the physiology is that.
cortisol released by your adrenal glands break down glycogen stores which is the way your body may stores glucose so glycogen is a long chain of a bunch of attached glucose molecules stored in your liver or night or at night or for needing use you heard about people going to run a marathon and they do.
You know carb loading so they'll eat that pasta dinner well.
It's been things that have debunked that because you could only store so much glycogen but you will store glycogen in your liver how you release that is through cortisol release so if you're under stress you're going to release more cortisol it's going to increase your glucose levels because it's breaking down the glycogen stores in your liver increasing.
circulating glucose because under stress you burn more glucose so you need it so think about that but also when you wake up in the middle of the night.
What kicks in your adretals do so your adretals kick in you release cortisol and you will get a higher so if you sleep really good you sleep all night long.
You're going to have you know all things the same you're going to have a lower morning glucose and if you woke up four times to even go to the bathroom you just you were stressed you felt right back asleep you got up to go to the bathroom your blood glucose is going to be higher in the morning because you released cortisol just to get up to go to the bathroom.
That's the physiology on it.
So I apologize if we went long again and I talked too much but I do you know I think just the more educated everybody is I think the better I just think you then you can think through these things and make your own decisions.
That's why you need to listen to these things even if you know you can't stomach listening to me.
What it did like fast forward mode or something so I said like a chipmunk but you can still absorb some of the information question the person about the detox question make sure you do watch those videos on detoxification.
My favorite of all these courses is the auto immune because it's the last one I did and I think there's not a really good information in there.
Alright know that I'm praying for you guys and I hope you're praying for us and I love all of you and keep up the good fight know that the enemy wants you dead and you have to just keep fighting against it.
Alright bye bye.